Bueno, cuando un hueso se rompe, digamos que una radiografía ofrece una
respuesta binaria y muy limpia.
Hay una línea blanca irregular, el médico señala la pantalla y
pues el problema es súper evidente.
Claro, es algo mecánico, muy visual.
Exacto. Pero cuando el hígado comienza a fallar, las aguas del diagnóstico
se vuelven increíblemente turbias.
De repente nos enfrentamos a un órgano que afecta el cerebro, los riñones,
la sangre.
Sí, y todo el sistema vascular.
De maneras que a simple vista parecen no estar conectadas para nada.
Totalmente. Por eso hoy nuestra inmersión a fondo tiene una misión muy clara.
Vamos a desempacar los materiales de estudio de Power Semiotics, que están
diseñados específicamente para la preparación de exámenes médicos como el
USMLE Step 2 CK.
Que es un examen súper riguroso, o sea, no perdona.
No, para nada. Y el objetivo aquí es comprender exactamente cómo
ese daño hepático o microscópico se convierte en una falla sistémica
masiva.
Queremos dominar los mecanismos de la fibrosis hepática y todos sus marcadores
clínicos.
Tenemos guías interactivas, casos de gastroenterología y mucha biología por
explorar hoy.
Y me encanta que usemos estas fuentes de Parasemiotics porque su enfoque es súper
revelador.
Para dominar la medicina interna a este nivel, memorizar listas de síntomas de
forma independiente es una estrategia destinada al fracaso.
Sí, o sea, no basta con hacer tarjetas de memoria y ya.
Exacto. Los exámenes de licencia médica no evalúan tu memoria fotográfica.
Lo que realmente evalúan es la capacidad de conectar el qué con el por qué.
Cuando se comprende el mecanismo fisiopatológico subyacente, un síntoma que parece
aleatorio, digamos un temblor en las manos.
Ajá, el clásico temblor.
Sí, ese temblor deja de ser un dato aislado.
Se convierte en la conclusión matemática e inevitable de una cascada biológica
que, fíjate, empezó a nivel celular.
Y esa cascada celular es precisamente el punto de partida obligatorio para nuestra
charla de hoy.
O sea, para entender a un paciente que llega a la sala de urgencias con el abdomen
completamente distendido,
primero hay que hacer un zoom microscópico, ¿verdad?
Así es, ir directo a la arquitectura del hígado.
Correcto. El material de estudio señala que todo este desastre comienza con
un tipo de célula muy específica.
Y se ubican en un área llamada el espacio de DICE.
Estamos hablando de las células estrelladas hepáticas.
También súper conocidas como células de hito.
Las células de hito, exacto.
Leyendo cómo se comportan, mi primer instinto fue imaginarlas como una
especie de, no sé, como arañas durmientes dentro del hígado.
Arañas durmientes, a ver, explícame eso.
Pues sí, o sea, están ahí en hibernación, muy tranquilas, pero de pronto cuando son
irritadas por un virus o por toxinas, se despiertan furiosas.
Y comienzan a tejer una red inmensa y súper rígida de colágeno y
esa red termina asfixiando al órgano.
Fíjate que esa analogía de la red de araña funciona perfectamente para visualizar
el daño estructural.
Es muy gráfica.
Pero el matiz biológico aquí es que en un hígado sano, estas células no
están simplemente inútiles o durmiendo todo el día.
Ah, tienen un trabajo de día.
Sí, su trabajo diurno, por así decirlo, es ser unidades de almacenamiento.
De hecho, guardan la mayor parte de la vitamina A de todo el cuerpo humano.
¡Guau! No sabía que era la mayor parte.
Sí, es su función principal.
El problema ocurre cuando el hígado sufre una lesión constante.
Esa irritación crónica provoca que las células de hito dejen caer de golpe sus
reservas de vitamina A.
Y ahí es cuando mutan y se transforman en miofibroblastos.
O sea, cambian de forma y de función por completo.
Básicamente se convierten en fábricas descontroladas de colágeno tipo 1.
Y el colágeno tipo 1 es tejido cicatricial, es sumamente
rígido.
Exactamente.
O sea, imaginemos el hígado como una esponja altamente vascularizada.
Está diseñada para que la sangre fluya a través de ella de una manera lenta y
muy eficiente para poder ser filtrada.
Claro, como un filtro de agua gigante.
Sí, pero si esas células de hito llenan la esponja con una red de
cicatrices rígidas, toda esa arquitectura colapsa.
Los canales microscópicos por donde normalmente pasa la sangre se estrechan o
de plano se bloquean por completo.
Y ese simple cambio mecánico es el origen de todas las complicaciones
vasculares, las que siempre preguntan en los exámenes.
Totalmente. Porque transforma un órgano que debería ser un filtro suave en
un muro de concreto, literal.
Un muro de concreto. Y si el hígado se convierte en un muro, pues la sangre
que intenta atravesarlo va a tener que buscar otra salida porque no puede
simplemente detenerse.
Así es. La presión tiene que liberarse por algún lado.
Pero bueno, antes de llegar a ese colapso total, las guías de Power
Semiotics hacen mucho énfasis en rastrear qué fue exactamente lo que irritó a
estas células en primer lugar. Hay que conectar rápidamente la etiología con su
marcador clínico.
Sí, el origen del problema.
Por ejemplo, el virus de la hepatitis C se busca con anticuerpos
anti-BHC. O la enfermedad metabólica, el NASH,
se identifica por un aumento de la ecogenicidad en el ultrasonido.
O sea, es básicamente grasa infiltrada brillando en la pantalla, ¿verdad?
Exacto. Brilla porque el hígado está lleno de esteatosis, de grasa.
Pero fíjate que el que más me llama la atención de las fuentes es el marcador para
la enfermedad hepática alcohólica.
El material indica que se debe buscar una proporción de las enzimas AST
sobre ALT mayor a 2 a 1.
El famoso ratio 2 a 1.
Sí, ese mismo. Pero, a ver, ¿por qué el alcohol produce esa matemática enzimática
tan, pero tan específica?
Bueno, ese es un detalle clásico de los exámenes que ilustra de manera perfecta el
por qué detrás del qué.
O sea, la AST y la ALT son enzimas que viven dentro de las células
hepáticas.
Cuando la célula muere, por alguna razón, estas enzimas se derraman en el torrente
sanguíneo.
Hasta ahí tiene sentido. Hay daño celular, las enzimas suben en la sangre.
Claro. Sin embargo, el daño por alcohol es muy particular.
Primero, hay que entender que el alcohol es una toxina que ataca directamente a las
mitocondrias de las células.
Y resulta que una gran cantidad de la enzima AST se aloja
precisamente dentro de las mitocondrias.
Ah, ok.
Entonces, al destruir la mitocondria con el alcohol, se libera de golpe toda esa
AST extra.
Exacto. Tienes un pico masivo de AST.
¿Y qué pasa entonces con la ALT?
¿Por qué esa no sube igual y rompe la proporción?
Ahí está el truco bioquímico.
Para que el cuerpo pueda sintetizar la enzima ALT, necesita
un cofactor, específicamente la vitamina B6.
Y bueno, los pacientes con alcoholismo crónico casi siempre tienen una deficiencia
severa de vitamina B6.
Ah, claro, por la mala nutrición y los problemas de absorción.
Así es. Entonces, como no hay vitamina B6, el hígado simplemente no puede fabricar
suficiente ALT para que se derrame en la sangre, incluso si las células están
muriendo.
Qué interesante.
Entonces, el resultado es un aumento masivo de AST por ese
daño mitocondrial directo, combinado con una ALT que está deprimida
porque le falta su vitamina.
Exactamente.
Por eso la proporción siempre supera el 2 a 1.
No es que sea solo un número que hay que memorizar, es el reflejo de la
desnutrición y la toxicidad celular ocurriendo al mismo tiempo.
Eso tiene muchísimo sentido.
Es la biología dictando literalmente los resultados del laboratorio.
Ahora, sin importar si fue el alcohol o un virus lo que desató esta
fibrosis,
las fuentes hacen una distinción monumental entre dos fases de la enfermedad.
Sí, la etapa compensada y la descompensada.
Exacto. En la fase de cirrosis compensada, el paciente parece estar bien.
Tal vez tiene algo de fatiga, las plaquetas bajan un poco,
pero el hígado, a pesar de estar lleno de cicatrices,
todavía logra hacer el trabajo mínimo para mantener el cuerpo a flote.
Sobrevive, a duras penas, pero lo logra.
Pero luego cruzamos esa línea hacia la cirrosis descompensada.
Y es como si el cuerpo entrara en caída libre.
El material enumera ictericia, sangrado interno y una
acumulación masiva de líquido en el abdomen que llamamos asitis.
La asitis es uno de los signos más visuales de que el sistema falló.
Y aquí es donde la guía de estudio se vuelve súper estricta.
Dice que para confirmar que este líquido abdominal es realmente causado por la
cirrosis,
hay que calcular el gradiente SAG, y este debe ser mayor a 1.1
gramos por decilitro.
El famoso gradiente de albúmina.
Sí, pero aquí te quiero hacer un poco de pushback.
O sea, lo que no entiendo del todo es por qué hay tanta obsesión matemática con
esto.
Si un paciente tiene el abdomen lleno de litros de líquido y un historial
larguísimo de daño hepático,
¿no es súper obvio lo que está pasando?
Suena obvio, sí.
Entonces, ¿por qué tenemos que restar la albúmina del suero menos la albúmina del
líquido acítico
para obtener un 1.1 exacto?
Bueno, porque en medicina clínica, asumir lo obvio es
extremadamente peligroso.
El abdomen puede llenarse de líquido por muchísimas razones
que no tienen absolutamente nada que ver con el hígado.
¿Como cuáles?
Pues podría ser un cáncer de ovario que se ha diseminado, por ejemplo,
o una infección grave como la tuberculosis peritoneal.
La obsesión de las juntas médicas con el cálculo del SAG
radica en que es la prueba física innegable de la
hipertensión portal.
Y esto nos lleva de vuelta al muro de concreto del que hablábamos.
Justamente. Fíjate que la sangre fluye normalmente desde los intestinos hacia el
hígado a través de la vena porta.
Pero si el hígado está rígido por la fibrosis, la sangre literalmente choca
contra una pared.
No puede avanzar.
No puede. Y la presión dentro de esa vena porta aumenta drásticamente.
O sea, piensa en una manguera de jardín a la que le pones el pulgar en el extremo.
Se hincha.
Sí. La presión dentro de la manguera sube rapidísimo y el agua empieza a filtrarse
por los poros del plástico.
En el cuerpo humano, esa alta presión hidrostática empuja físicamente el
componente acuoso de la sangre fuera de los vasos y cae hacia la cavidad abdominal.
Ah, claro. Y como es pura presión mecánica empujando el agua, las
moléculas grandes, como las proteínas, se quedan atrapadas en las venas.
Ellas no caben por los poros.
Ese es el mecanismo exacto. Y la proteína principal de la sangre es la albúmina.
Como la albúmina es demasiado grande para ser exprimida por esa presión, se queda
en el torrente sanguíneo.
Mientras que el líquido que cae al abdomen es pura agua sin proteínas.
Así es. Por lo tanto, si mides la albúmina en la sangre, va a estar alta en
comparación.
Y si mides la albúmina en el líquido abdominal, va a estar muy bajita.
O sea que la diferencia o el gradiente va a ser amplio, mayor a ese famoso
1.1 que piden en el examen.
Exacto. Ese simple número te confirma matemáticamente que la física
de la alta presión está actuando.
No es un tumor secretando líquido por su cuenta.
Pero a ver, hay un escenario que me genera duda leyendo esto.
¿Qué pasa si el paciente tiene insuficiencia cardíaca?
Porque si el corazón falla, la sangre también se acumula, la presión en las venas
también sube y el líquido igual se filtra al abdomen, ¿no?
Sí, claro, la presión se devuelve.
Entonces el SAG seguiría siendo mayor a 1.1 en ese caso.
Ese es un matiz clínico excelente para los exámenes.
Y la respuesta es sí. Una insuficiencia cardíaca derecha severa también genera
hipertensión venosa y te va a dar un SAG mayor a 1.1.
Entonces, ¿cómo los diferencias si el número es el mismo?
Para diferenciarlos, los médicos observan la proteína total en ese líquido acítico.
Un hígado cirrótico está tan dañado que no permite que salgan proteínas casi de
ningún tipo. Así que la proteína total en el líquido es bajísima.
Ok, muy baja.
Pero en la insuficiencia cardíaca, el hígado y los vasos sanguíneos están
estructuralmente intactos, solo están congestionados, por lo que las proteínas sí
logran filtrarse un poco más hacia el líquido.
Entendido. Pero bueno, en términos generales de los exámenes, un SAG mayor a
1.1 básicamente grita hay hipertensión en el sistema
y te ayuda a descartar causas de una como el cáncer o la tuberculosis.
Completamente. Te enfoca en un problema de presiones, no de tumores o infecciones.
Queda clarísimo. Es como la firma hidrostática de un sistema que está
bloqueado. Y bueno, una vez que sabemos que el hígado está fallando y está
descompensado, la medicina clínica exige medir exactamente
qué tan cerca del abismo se encuentra el paciente.
Sí, hay que cuantificar la gravedad.
Y las herramientas estandarizadas que mencionan los módulos para medir esta
gravedad son las escalas de Child Pew y MELD.
Leyéndolas, me da la impresión de que actúan como una especie de
historial crediticio del hígado, evaluando qué tanto daño acumulado tiene
el órgano en ese momento.
Es una buena analogía.
Pero me pregunto si son simplemente observacionales o si realmente
dictan el manejo médico de forma activa en la vida real.
Actúan definitivamente como un historial crediticio, pero uno que dicta si recibes
o no una oportunidad de seguir viviendo.
Wow, así de serias son.
Sí, y lo interesante de estas dos escalas es ver cómo ha evolucionado la medicina.
Verás, Child Pew es una escala más antigua.
Utiliza factores de laboratorio como la bilirrubina y la albúmina, lo cual está
bien, pero también incluye elementos muy subjetivos.
¿Subjetivos como cuáles?
Como el grado clínico de asitis o la gravedad de la confusión mental del paciente.
El gran problema con eso es que, bueno, la confusión leve para un médico de guardia
podría parecer confusión moderada para otro médico en el siguiente turno.
Y claro, eso introduce un sesgo humano gigantesco cuando estás tomando decisiones
críticas de vida o muerte.
Exactamente. Por eso mismo se introdujo el MELD, que significa Modelo para la
Enfermedad Hepática en Etapa Terminal.
El MELD elimina todo lo subjetivo de la ecuación.
¿Cómo funciona entonces?
Es pura matemática, fría y dura, basada exclusivamente
en valores de laboratorio que son totalmente objetivos, principalmente la
bilirrubina, el tiempo de coagulación INR y, de manera muy importante,
la creatinina sérica.
Momento, la creatinina es un marcador clásico de la función de los riñones.
¿Por qué una escala que está diseñada para medir la gravedad del hígado le daría
tanto peso a los riñones?
Ah, porque eso refleja el colapso sistémico del que hablábamos al principio.
Cuando la hipertensión
portal es tan severa, el cuerpo entra en pánico e intenta compensar dilatando y
contrayendo
diferentes vasos sanguíneos. Tratando de ajustar la presión a la fuerza.
Sí, y en ese intento
desesperado, los riñones de repente se quedan sin suficiente flujo sanguíneo.
Y empiezan a fallar.
Pero no porque el riñón en sí esté enfermo, sino porque el hígado, digamos, arruinó
la
circulación global. O sea, el riñón es una víctima secundaria del hígado.
Exacto. Esto se
conoce como síndrome hepatorrenal. Y cuando la creatinina sube en la sangre por
esta falla,
el puntaje MELT se dispara hacia arriba.
Qué locura. Y ese puntaje MELT no es un simple
ejercicio académico. O sea, se utiliza a nivel nacional para priorizar la lista
oficial de
trasplantes. Si tu MELT es de 40, significa que el riesgo de mortalidad a 90 días
es altísimo y
saltas inmediatamente al tope de la lista para recibir un órgano nuevo.
Es decir, que pasamos
de unas células microscópicas perdiendo su vitamina A en silencio a
una ecuación matemática
que decide a nivel nacional quién recibe un trasplante de emergencia.
La progresión de esto es francamente implacable.
Sí, es una cascada devastadora cuando no se detiene.
Y creo que todo esto nos prepara de manera perfecta para el escenario donde esta
teoría se aplique en tiempo real.
Vamos a analizar el caso de aprendizaje basado en problemas que viene incluido en
las fuentes, ¿te parece?
Me parece excelente. Vamos a ver el cuadro clínico.
Perfecto. Se trata de un hombre de 56 años con un historial severo de consumo
de alcohol.
Es traído a urgencias por su familia porque su estado ha empeorado drásticamente en
las últimas 24 horas.
El material describe una confusión mental muy profunda, letargo
extremo y desorientación.
Síntomas neurológicos graves.
Sí. Y físicamente tiene ictericia, el abdomen está súper
tenso por el líquido
y presenta estos angiomas en forma de araña en la piel del pecho.
Pero fíjate que el síntoma que el caso resalta de inmediato es un temblor
rítmico y espasmódico
Cuando el paciente extiende las manos, lo que conocemos como asterixis, el
clásico temblor aleteante. Exacto.
Leyendo esto, te digo la verdad.
Si yo veo un paciente profundamente confundido y con temblores motores tan
evidentes, mi primer pensamiento neurológico sería un derrame cerebral
o quizá una hemorragia o un tumor.
humor. ¿Cómo es posible que un hígado cicatrizado provoque una crisis
neurológica tan aguda? Es una
pregunta buenísima. Esa desconexión aparente entre lo que pasa en el abdomen y
lo que pasa en el
cerebro es, de hecho, lo que hace a la encefalopatía hepática una
complicación fascinante desde el
punto de vista médico. A ver, explícame esa conexión.
Piensa en el hígado sano como la
principal planta de tratamiento de residuos del cuerpo.
Uno de los mayores residuos tóxicos que
producimos diariamente proviene de las bacterias en nuestros propios intestinos.
Estas bacterias
se dedican a descomponer las proteínas de los alimentos que comemos.
Y en ese proceso generan
desechos. Exactamente. Y el principal desecho es el amoníaco.
Normalmente ese amoníaco viaja por
la sangre directamente al hígado, donde es neutralizado.
El hígado lo convierte en urea,
que es inofensiva. Y luego simplemente lo orinamos.
Pero en el caso de nuestro paciente de 56 años,
esa planta de tratamiento está bloqueada por el tejido cicatricial de las células
de hito que
que mencionamos. Así es, el filtro está tapado.
Y el amoníaco, bueno, no se queda sentado esperando.
Al no poder ser procesado por el hígado, busca un desvío, entra a la circulación
general del
cuerpo y eventualmente viaja hacia arriba y llega al cerebro.
Uy, y me imagino que el amoníaco no
es nada amigable con el cerebro.
Es altamente tóxico para el sistema nervioso central.
Cruza
la barrera hematoencefálica con muchísima facilidad y altera por completo la
función
de los astrocitos y de los neurotransmisores.
O sea, un envenenamiento en toda regla.
Literalmente. Ese ambiente tóxico en el cerebro es lo que genera la
confusión profunda,
la alteración grave del ciclo del sueño y, por supuesto, ese característico
asterixis,
que no es otra cosa que el cerebro perdiendo de forma intermitente la capacidad de
mantener
el tono muscular en las manos.
Es increíble. Entonces,
el paciente está literalmente siendo envenenado por el proceso de digestión
normal de su propio
cuerpo. Exactamente. Sus propias bacterias lo están intoxicando.
Fíjate que la autoevaluación
del material de Power Semiotics hace una pregunta directa sobre el tratamiento
farmacológico
inmediato para revertir esto ahí mismo, en la sala de emergencias.
Las opciones que dan son
octreotida intravenosa, espironolactona, rifaximina sola
o lactulosa. Y la respuesta
correcta que exige el examen es la lactulosa.
Sí, la lactulosa es la primera línea indiscutible.
Y aquí es donde la farmacología me resulta un poco confusa.
O sea, la lactulosa es esencialmente un jarabe de azúcar súper denso, que a menudo
se usa como un simple laxante.
¿Cómo es que darle un laxante a un paciente logra revertir una crisis tóxica
severa en el cerebro?
Es que la brillantez de usar lactulosa radica en la química pura, no
solo en su efecto laxante, aunque eso ayuda.
O sea, purgarlo ayuda.
ayuda. Claro, porque acelera el tránsito intestinal y eso ayuda a expulsar
la materia fecal antes de
que las bacterias tengan más tiempo de producir más amoníaco.
Pero el mecanismo verdaderamente
de alto rendimiento, el que las juntas médicas exigen que comprendas, es el
concepto de la trampa
de iones. A ver, detente ahí.
¿Qué es una trampa de iones?
Bueno, la lactulosa es un azúcar sintético.
Los humanos no tenemos las enzimas para digerirla, pero las bacterias del colon sí.
Al comerse la
la lactulosa, estas bacterias fermentan y producen ácidos orgánicos como su
producto. O sea, que la
lactulosa básicamente baja el pH del colon, haciéndolo un ambiente superácido.
Exactamente. Y
aquí es donde ocurre la magia química.
El amoníaco tóxico, que en su fórmula química es NH3, es un
gas. Y como gas puede cruzar libremente de un lado a otro la pared intestinal hacia
la sangre. Y
viajar al cerebro, como dijimos.
Sí, pero al encontrarse de repente en un colon con un ambiente
muy ácido, ese amoníaco NH3 se une a un ión de
hidrógeno libre de los ácidos y al unirse se
transforma químicamente en amonio, que es NH4 positivo.
Ah, cambió su estructura.
Y lo más
importante, ganó una carga eléctrica positiva.
Al tener esa carga, se vuelve físicamente incapaz
de cruzar las membranas celulares. Ya no puede regresar a la sangre.
Se queda completamente
atrapado en el intestino. Wow.
O sea, lo captura químicamente en el intestino para que el cuerpo
lo elimine con las heces, en lugar de absorberlo de nuevo hacia la sangre.
Es un mecanismo de
limpieza indirecto para el cerebro.
Es una trampa iónica perfecta y sumamente elegante.
Y por eso
las otras opciones en el examen son distracciones basadas en otras complicaciones
de la misma
cirrosis. Claro, como la espironolactona.
Exacto, que es un diurético excelente para manejar la
asitis, tratando de que el paciente orine el exceso de líquido.
Pero siendo realistas,
no hará absolutamente nada por neutralizar la toxina que ya está en el cerebro.
Y la octreotida, según recuerdo de los apuntes, reduce
la presión portal
y se usa para detener el sangrado de las várices esofágicas, ¿no?
Son estas venas dilatadas en la garganta que están a punto de estallar.
Así es. Y aunque la viñeta menciona que el paciente tiene un historial de sangrado,
su queja principal hoy, la razón por la que lo trajeron a urgencias, es la
encefalopatía.
Ese detalle del historial, de hecho, es súper interesante.
La viñeta menciona que él vomitó sangre hace un año.
Eso nos confirma que la presión en su vena porta es tan y tan alta
que las venas del esófago se estuvieron reventando bajo la presión, simplemente
buscando una vía de escape alternativa hacia el corazón.
Una vía de escape que puede ser letal, por cierto.
Totalmente. Con ese antecedente, me imagino que debió haber estado bajo algún
tratamiento profiláctico crónico desde entonces, quizá tomando un beta
bloqueador para mantener la presión venosa lo más baja posible.
Pero el enfoque agudo para salvarle la vida hoy, en este instante
de confusión severa, es bajar esos niveles de amoníaco usando la lactulosa.
Y ese es verdaderamente el corazón del diagnóstico clínico.
Saber priorizar.
Exacto.
Porque el paciente tiene retención de líquidos masiva, tiene riesgo inminente de
volver a sangrar y tiene una falla sintética generalizada, todo al mismo tiempo.
Pero la toxina neurológica es la crisis activa que amenaza su vida y que
requiere intervención inmediata.
Todo tu conocimiento debe canalizarse hacia la resolución del problema
más letal en ese milisegundo específico.
Si observamos todo este viaje biológico desde una perspectiva panorámica,
es asombroso. Comenzamos con unas pequeñas células de almacenamiento
en el espacio de dice que pierden su vitamina A y mutan.
Un cambio tan microscópico.
Sí, y estas tejedoras alteran por completo la
estructura de un órgano entero, lo cual cambia la hemodinámica de la sangre,
y eso lo vemos evidenciado por el gradiente SAG mayor a 1.1.
Ese bloqueo mecánico causa un efecto dominó que paraliza los riñones,
eleva la escala MELD y permite que las toxinas intestinales lleguen
libres al cerebro, requiriendo una trampa ácida en el colon para revertirlo.
Es una línea recta perfecta de causa y efecto.
Y fíjate que comprender esa línea recta es la diferencia fundamental entre
simplemente adivinar respuestas en un examen de opción múltiple y realmente
practicar medicina de alto nivel.
Así es.
Sin embargo, al observar de cerca todo este complejo proceso de
destrucción, surge una reflexión muy profunda para que
consideremos hacia el futuro de la medicina.
Adelante, me encantan las ideas que desafían un poco el conocimiento establecido.
Pues, si aceptamos que toda esta cascada clínica
catastrófica, o sea, desde la asitis resistente hasta el coma
hepático, es la consecuencia mecánica directa de la acumulación de colágeno, y
sabemos con certeza que los responsables únicos de producir ese colágeno son las
células estrelladas hepáticas, la gran frontera de la hepatología
cambia por completo.
¿En qué sentido?
En que, ¿qué sucedería si se descubriera una vía farmacológica
dirigida, pero no para manejar los síntomas como hacemos hoy, sino para obligar a
esos miofibroblastos a revertir su mutación?
Si logramos que esas células simplemente vuelvan a dormir
y retomen su función pacífica de almacenar vitaminas antes de que la
cicatrización sea permanente, ¿no estaríamos presenciando el fin de la cirrosis
como una enfermedad terminal e irreversible?
O sea, literalmente apagar la maquinaria que causa el daño en lugar de
solo tratar de limpiar el desastre que va dejando su paso.
Es un pensamiento súper provocador y francamente una razón
espectacular para que quienes nos escuchan sigan profundizando en
la fisiopatología.
Definitivamente, ahí está el futuro.
Y bueno, es todo el tiempo que tenemos por hoy en nuestro análisis a fondo sobre
los mecanismos de la fibrosis hepática y este excelente material de Power
Semiotics. Es fundamental continuar explorando la biología celular y
siempre, siempre cuestionando el por qué de cada marcador de laboratorio.
Porque cuando haces eso, las piezas del rompecabezas siempre encajan.
Exactamente. Las piezas del rompecabezas clínico siempre caerán en su lugar.
Muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos y hasta la próxima inmersión.